we begin with this a woman accusing
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh of
assaulting her in high school has to
decide by tomorrow morning if she will
testify before a Senate committee Senate
Judiciary Chairman Chuck Grassley says
Christine Blasi Ford can tell her a
story in public or she can tell it in
private
he also says Judiciary Committee aides
would travel to interview her her lawyer
said last night that Ford believes a
full nonpartisan investigation of this
matter is needed and she's willing to
cooperate but the lawyer said the
committee's stated plan to move forward
with a hearing that has only two
witnesses is not a fair or good-faith
investigation
President Trump could order the FBI to
launch an investigation but he says the
Senate should handle it the president
said yesterday he wants to hear from
Ford joining us now is CBS News senior
national security analyst Fran Townsend
she was homeland security and
counterterrorism adviser to President
George W Bush and worked alongside
Cavanaugh Fran good morning so what role
should the FBI play in this you know the
FBI even if that you were to reopen the
background investigation under no
circumstances will they take a view on
credibility it's actually part of the
regulations the Justice Department
regulations that's not their job so they
would interview dr. Ford they would
interview Cavanaugh they would probably
try to interview mark judge the third
person that dr. Ford says was present
but it in the end this is going to come
down because of it's more than it's
almost 36 years old the allegation it's
going to come down to credibility and so
in the end the Judiciary Committee and
if the hearing is public the American
people are going to be the judges of
this you know so I'm not sure what gets
added to it by having the FBI do these
interviews in advance the tabouli Fran
how long does an investigation like that
take oh this is not going to look if you
did order an investigation we shouldn't
worry about a delay right it you have
the three interviews you may have two or
three others if there is some allegation
that others might have some memory of it
but there's a half dozen interviews to
be done each will have a 302 that's the
FBI written report behind it this is a
couple of days this is not weeks or
months well as a former federal
prosecutor would you put a witness on
the stand without some
investigation you know Gail if this was
if you were talking about a criminal
trial my view might be different right
where I want to know in advance because
I would have the opportunity to
cross-examine witnesses but I'd take you
back to the Anita Hill example right
this is a that's an example where
President George HW Bush did Bree did
open reopen the investigation based on
her allegations and look at how those
302s were used they were used it was a
brutal brutal cross-examination of her
in public I'm not sure that's something
that that's a model we really want to
follow when you say 302s what is that
you said how those 302s were used
sorry that's when the FBI doesn't
interview they write a report and it's
called that's the number of the form
they fill out it's called a 302 that's
what would then be handed over to the
Judiciary Committee if the FBI did it
and they would have that as a basis upon
which to question her so are you saying
an FBI investigation might actually not
even be helpful to her at this point
that's exactly right look and I don't
think it's helpful you know she's asked
for she through her lawyer has asked for
this FBI investigation and I think that
makes her look political look she has
this is it very difficult she's come
under incredible scrutiny and criticism
look I I feel for her it's taken real
courage for her to step up here but I
think she ought to tell her story she's
got a story to tell and whether that's
publicly or privately she ought to be
given the opportunity to tell that story
and she ought to want to avoid that as
much as is possible the politics of this
well that's why she wants to do it to an
FBI agent and that Senate investigators
Fran well that's right but in the end
this Nora this is going to be about her
telling her story and the to the extent
she's telling it to anybody else where
those are Senate investigators or the
FBI she's gonna be she's her own best
advocate here if she can get the
opportunity to tell her story and get it
out there then it's up to Kavanaugh to
be able to refute that all right Fran
Townsend thank you very much friend